from what I hear you you're almost done
with with the with the next album ya ali
is mixing it right now you know we're
just waiting on the road we just want to
present it in a real cool way you know
it's a lot of you are like everybody's
just being I feel like everybody's being
very creative with how to present in our
music definitely like you know how like
Nipsey Nipsey us we just did this nice
big release [__] was crazy that was
crazy like you know i just i just really
like i like how you know we're just
being everybody's being a lot more
creative presentation Nancy this
question growing up in a record store
like you said if I was over at my homies
crib actually got his filming us right
now at work and he's got a fast just
random vinyl collection work just look
at the vinyl or I feel like the artwork
used to be so [__] crazy like like it
wasn't there was no photoshop and
[__] had crazy artwork right
how important is that like when you when
it's time for you to come up with the
hard work you haven't already for the
next album like like when we you know
how that process come up I know I'm
definitely worked by that oh yeah that
was like pretty much like the majority
of my job was to let you know take care
of the inventory you've seen so I so
many come back then do the XO discovers
covers in the illustrations you know so
you know I gotta have you know I have to
prove that you're actually kind of
seemed like you know where a lot of
artists how they went about coming up
with their helpers like the correlation
between their cover an hour if there is
a correlation between the cover and now
just different just just different
strokes of genius you know an exam
definitely on the album I assume of
course you forgot the TD fam it's a
given um
from what I heard me inside were talking
earlier said he might have joined on
there that might have a pop in from
someone who might be in jail possible
maybe I don't know we won't say that
name but bus there is that ecstatic has
a big mouth I thought he played he was
playing the cards at home so i wouldn't
say who's on one camera yeah we all
knows that is I'm very excited for based
off of that what I heard I'm very
excited for me I'm gonna turn into yes
your palm bow but who's who's on
Kenyon's can you tell us anybody who's
on the other I mean I can't you know
okay just it's just like I said just
just because no we're just trying I'm
just trying to come on you gotta come up
the right presentation exactly exactly
but you know we'll say like you know
like dub sack I just I just released dub
sack yeah yeah yeah that's that's pretty
much that's one of the cornerstones at a
help you know the man it's just album is
just about progression I feel like it's
just about not just not just not my
profession but powerful question as a
team yeah that's what's up um I know
that Schoolboy Q and Kendrick have their
deals and their through interscope yes
j-rocks put out music through strange
and you each each of your project so you
can go on support and by I've just been
kind of straight to you can get them on
itunes on this next project is there
going to be a greater distribution
situation could be straight through TDE
like with the previous to this one knows
brother will be straight through TD ok
just like Bruce I'm
only one that's on the side and on top
of that you probably I mean that could
be a good daddy that can be good and bad
though because there's things you can do
you'll have to worry about a [__]
radiance in absolutely but I mean I just
don't getting tell me that I mean I
think I think you know to be honest are
just kind of I think like artists today
are talking too much about their
business plans and strategy and more
soda a little about being dope you know
I'm saying everybody's so concerned
about where they're positioned in
opportunities that they have versus the
content that's Rocha so um I've heard
rumblings of a possible collaboration
I'm with you Danny Brown and rocky is
that even like anywhere like is that
just is that just some rumors motor is
already concrete to know that [__]
though really like we really like you
know [__] around with like when we
went on I like hopped on the bus when I
when they all went out it was a sad
Danny Boy attribute yeah remember that
have you know I hopped on the bus and we
all got a chance to buy about it you
know all I qual similar in a lot of ways
you know the whole druggies would always
type of vibe but they're so that could
definitely happen is there any music
done look with a q3 like we haven't
heard yet not yet so it's just kind of
being discussed kind of like that j Cole
Kendrick healthy everyone oh yeah I
probably need to know I think you know
that i need to put out without out
probably it's weird where's the bomb
yeah yeah yeah for sure man so the album
hopefully 2014 yeah i mean i'm gonna
girlie I want to get it out this year
man I want to or maybe around Christmas
shaky I'll Christmas second that would
be pretty tight but uh definitely if not
this year early 2014 I'm curious cuz
you're you're a music head like me right
if I head like me man oh poor by two or
three DS think of the most underrated
emcees like ever like I always have this
talk with a lot of people like who's
some artists MC wise you already
mentioned candidate so I feel like I see
someone who doesn't underrated in
cannabis review I was quick but who are
some other do to you who you are fans of
that you thinking never really get their
best doing when the best gets talked to
us now so that's what I always say sean
price that's a great question Sean P is
incredible tool
that's a great [__] question
because I mean I really no man no you
were like like you really [__] hip
hot dude right yeah I'm trying that's it
that's a great question can and you know
I really don't like that word like
underrated they try to you know a lot of
people trying to get where I work yeah
but I feel like in the present time
people could be under I'm talking about
you know very nice nor I'm really trying
here I'm trying to give you a good 10
this a couple guys I was like supposed
to go man better
like of course like
like
like I feel like like like Joe button
like Joe buttons like first album to me
was like a minute how about 10 minutes
like you like was first album alone like
it was the whole [__] out was crazy
so you know for him tonight you know be
releasing for handing out you for a
friend and not get props for that out
now it's crazy that's that's what I'm
saying like I don't feel like you know
you don't get any do for that out of you
know I don't think that turned around
properly was
that's a good question I mean if it
twisted you mention your victim and yeah
which is very underrated twisted what I
mean you know it's just kind of like I
think these are guys are you know
they're kind of like pioneers are kind
of like you know showing us so you know
the gifts and the curses of the ship you
know because I think like like the drill
button situation like I remember that
time vividly I remember I remember Brian
and out here because that's when that's
when the internet he that was also i
remember that they have problems because
keith murray and Englert robin at the
same time yeah and I would hear that to
a book more importantly now was when the
internet and that's where mine wire on
that fair sharing on their share and
[__] you know my here's a key because
you know I was at the shop and you know
sales were we're declining you saw that
firsthand so yeah you were right there
yeah exactly so yes right it's just it's
been a few others like that I've just
watched it you know I've seen how the
game as you know made a maid or treated
them and that's what's up man its kind
of crazy you seem kind of every facet of
the game being on the end of you know
being this the record store being a fan
and now you're doing your thing man well
a man much love to you brother music
you're making real [__] man you've been
booking all [__] day missions make
sure you go get the out whatever comes
out if you don't guide on coming soon if
you don't got the first two joints godec
control system which is crazy messages
on itunes or support i always tell
everybody that artists that like like TT
may not put out so many Lucy so much
free [__] man's when it's time to
support support that [__]
appreciate you guys on my god huh yeah
you